der jubel kannte am samstagabend in tel
aviv keine grenzen mehr
denn gerade erst war der sieger des
finales der diesjährigen ausgabe des
eurovision song contests bekannt gegeben
worden und gewonnen hat am ende der
niederländer danken lorenz mit seiner
pop ballade a cage der überglückliche
künstler rang nach dem siegreichen
bühnenauftritt in israel mit seinen
emotionen keine worte ich kann das nicht
in worten beschreiben
darüber kann ich kein lied schreiben
denn mir fehlen einfach die worte ich
bin gerade so glücklich mein traum ist
wirklich wahr geworden
mit diesem sieg steht dann auch der
austragungsort der nächsten esc
veranstaltung fest denn damit wird der
eurovision song contest 2020 also im
kommenden jahr nach 44 jahren wieder
einmal in den niederlanden stattfinden